[Music]
all right well first of all hello
everyone and welcome to our second class
second lecture which is how to play like
pro okay and what I wanted to say is
it's not easy to play like a pro on on
the contrary it's really really really
tough now being a professional chess
player has a lot of upsides and
downsides one of the upsides is you're
your own boss but one of the downsides
is that things don't often go according
to your plans
ooh not good not good
in professional chess you have to have
your opening novelty the opening novelty
is to a chess professional what a
fast-draw was to the Old West
gunslingers so you work really really
hard to work on your opening chest
novelties and what if the guy doesn't
fall into them I remember that when I
was coming up as a professional I had
worked out some really really great
opening novelties and I get to the board
and I try to play them and my opponent
would deviate could get the novelty and
then somebody else
a year later played it like no that was
my novelty oh why why why so sometimes
you work really hard you prepare for a
tournament and nobody plays
the variation that you prepared for what
to do what to do it's really really
really tough and then somebody else gets
the novelty so we're going back to the
candidates tournament of two weeks ago
three weeks ago and here's a huge
matchup early in the tournament between
Levon Aronian is white against Vladimir
Kramnik who's black and as Vladimir
explained after the game it was about
two years ago that he had this opening
novelty all prepared and he never ever
got a chance to play it and wouldn't you
know it in the candidates tournament one
of the biggest stages in chess his
opponent walks into it here's one
example of a opening that I learned when
I was very young I was just starting
chess and
I'm supposed to be white
my opponents supposed to be black and
they're supposed to let me do this when
I first saw this variation and it has a
specific name this checkmate in pattern
fantastic the Queen you know the most
powerful piece on the board I'm
sacrificing my queen
so Bishop takes d1 can you see the
checkmate in two exactly yeah it is
Legault yeah that's right it is Legault
check mating pattern so I learned this I
memorized this and you know in 4,000
tournament games nobody even came close
to falling into my brilliant brilliant
really not even close I mean it was just
terrible terrible
nobody ever played this stuff what could
I do
anyway Levon Aronian white Vladimir
Kramnik black efore this is actually a
surprising opening move by Levon
so Levon has really known for Knight f3
c4 Catalan ready barks openings and E
for is where so there was somebody I
forget who who did the ceremonial
opening first move the honorary guest
you know comes and E for that that
person has played and you know every
smiles all around and you know Vladimir
Kramnik is expecting Levon to retract
the move and play his normal stuff and
boom it stays on the board it's like
whoa okay so of course Vladimir has
justifiably a great reputation as an
opening specialist and in particular the
Berlin defense he used it famously in
the year 2000 to neutralize Gary
Kasparov in their World Championship
match okay so obviously the Berlin will
not come as a surprise to LaVon and
LaVon wants to play a d2 d3 variation in
the in the in the famous 2000 match Gary
Kasparov is white when in what is called
the Berlin ending there's a four
sequence of moves that result in the
trade of Queens now this was a brilliant
choice by Vladimir Kramnik because Gary
Kasparov is one of the most fearsome
attacking players in the history of the
game and literally you know in the first
ten moves the Queen's come off the board
so what a great way to try to neutralize
Gary's attacking potential by trading
Queens and it worked out I'm not going
to say to perfection but it worked out
really really well for Vladimir so LaVon
wants nothing to do with that ending
he'll play d3 Bishop c5 and Bishop takes
c6 well this is a kind of a latest
wrinkle the professional players of
today are having a real real problem
getting an advantage with white in the
Berlin for example in this position
should you want to castle which you
normally would then there's this move
Knight d4 attacking army attacking this
bishop on
b5 so there's no time to capture this
pawn and after the nitrate Bishop takes
c3 Bishop back the position is
considered dead even black is going to
play C 6 and d6 so the other thing that
LaVon can do is he can stop black from
playing Knight d4 with the move c3
castles and lots and lots of tournament
games have gone from this exact position
and again and white has really been
struggling to find an advantage so LaVon
comes with it the latest wrinkle Bishop
takes c6 takes now of course this pawn
is not up for grabs yet you can't play
Knight takes e5 as much as you would
it's highly desirable as that maybe
there's a move Queen d4 and now thanks
to the threat of check mate in one as
well as Queen takes there's the line
that ends up in blacks favor oops
so you can't go for the pond that would
get you get your hand caught in the
cookie jar
castles okay but now now the pond is up
for grabs
defense Queen e7 LaVon of course
expected this and he says okay what I
want to do with white is I want to bring
my minor pieces into play and attack
this pawn on e5 92 to 94 then I want to
play Bishop e3 white voluntarily gave up
his LightSquared bishop so white is
trying to make an argument that blacks
light-square bishop is not going to find
it an effective square like is this
square that great it's okay this square
is probably a whole lot better but be
careful that pawn needs protection
so LaVon says I'm gonna play h3 and I'm
gonna leave it up to you yes now this is
we're playing like a pro comes in this
position has been played before there's
been a lot of experience with it
and Kramnik two years before the
candidates had had a hard look at this
position again
he's a Berlin specialist and he came to
an extraordinary realization
the best way of meeting an attack on the
flank is an attack in the center okay
Vladimir began to reason that he wants
to attack on the flank but he knows that
a counter punch in the center could
really destroy an attack on the flame
but he reasoned that the center is for
the moment closed it's not ready to be
burst open and he can attack on the
flank he would really love to play the
move g7 to g5 and let's assume for the
moment that the pawn cannot be captured
it could not be captured then he wants
to play g5 g4 force the trade and the
bishop will come to g4 and he will have
accomplished his goal which is getting
as a c8 bishop the LightSquared bishop
okay he played the move rook g8
[Music]
ooh what's up with that move okay so
move like rook g8 especially is played
by Vladimir Kramnik should really get
your spidey sense tingling like okay
this is weird
what's my opponent planning to do well
it's pretty darn obvious the opponent is
planning to go g5 g4 so if you play for
example a developing move to be
recommended by the way development is
good g5 Knight c4g for blasting away if
you take and you have it in your mind
that oh you'll just play g3 your next
move will be king h2 everything was
copacetic
splat rook takes g3 awesome this Bishop
on c5 of course pins the pawn on f2
cannot capture the rook okay so Livan of
course sees that he doesn't want to
allow that and he starts sinking well
how big is white blacks threat I want to
break in the center I want to play d3 d4
kind of moves and okay
pardon me let's imagine that
LaVon had played c3 a new variation g5
come and get them okay let's imagine
Bishop takes g5 what do you think black
should play h6 is a good move everybody
like h6 after h6 Bishop takes f6 Queen
takes f6 King h1 well you are a pawn
down is there a big follow-through
I don't see one Bishop takes h3 right
you do that first now on G takes h3 h6
and we can see that White's King has
been compromised and black is ready to
go castles and after recapturing the
bishop he's going to have a very very
powerful attack indeed so in
anticipation of Bishop takes h3 King h1
Knight h5 okay
now this whole line with g5
unfortunately does not deliver as the
goods first of all since there's no
Bishop takes h3 in the position white is
not even obliged to capture the night
why could even simply maintain the pin
you're just a pawn now
so yes spoiler alert
so black needs to prepare the move g5 he
plays the move Knight h5 so that the
Queen can help protect the the g5 square
and vladimir reasons that the knight
potentially could land on a really good
square near lavon's king c2 c3 now LaVon
is ready to strike in the center and try
to refute this premature King side
attack g5 and for a penny in for a pawn
pawn Knight takes e5
what do we think about this one okay
well first of all if we take the night
this Queen on d1 has made a discovered
attack against the night so Queen takes
Queen takes is actually working out
really good for white so Knight takes e5
g4 things are getting on boil now black
just wants to go Queen takes e5 thank
you very much also he's angling for g4
takes h3 and with the threat of that
can you guys spot a checkmate that might
occur after Knight takes g4 yes
yes sweet and that Queen is about to
land on h1 protected by the night again
the night can't be captured we see why
this Bishop is so very effective on c5
now essentially up to this move g4 this
had all been spotted two years before by
Vladimir this was his secret weapon he's
hoping to catch somebody in it he never
had this opportunity and especially
LaVon who isn't even an e4 player as
well right smack dab into his
professional preparation okay lavon's
facing a lot of issues here Queen takes
e5 is becoming a very serious threat g4
takes h3 is a very serious threat and
he's got to do something yes inland okay
D for D for okay bishops attack the
bishop drops back again now you can't
take on g4 for a much more simple reason
now you still have a checkmate but this
time it will be checkmate on the h2
square
thanks to this bishop now supporting the
Queen so that that pawn on g4
untouchable but look at White's army I
mean except for this errant Knight that
somehow is on e5 everybody's on the
first rank not good not good you know
you've lost the opening battle when all
of your pieces are still in their
barracks I haven't got into into the
game so LaVon does his best he's trying
to keep the King side
as closed as possible g2 g3 Bishop takes
pawn takes Queen takes so glad Amir has
won back his pawn but the threats to
White's King are still there there are
ideas of sacrificing a knight Knight
takes g3 followed by Queen takes g3 this
pawn well even though there's an open e
file it would be hanging with check and
LaVon said you know what I just want to
get out of here
intact let me trade Queens well one of
the cardinal guidelines is not a rule
that it's a very very good guideline
when you're attacking your opponent try
to avoid trading off you're attacking
pieces so Queen takes d4 was a very
reasonable move to trade and to take
upon but LaVon had said okay my king is
relatively safe I'm down upon but it's
not the end of the world upon on h3
isn't going anywhere and in the meantime
Knight c3 I'll have good development yes
please
Knight takes g3 now yes first of all it
is legal very very important to check it
out Queen takes g3 I think there's a
move queen III we could still probably
continue right Queen h4 some some
devilish attacking possibilities what I
think white really is desperate to do is
to trade Queens Oh Lord you know just to
try to keep offering that trade of
Queens what Vladimir did is he just said
okay I'll back up with my queen no harm
no
I still want to keep my attacking
options and maybe on a good day my rook
can even come to d8 with a tempo maybe
I'll play b6 Bishop b7 c5 or rook to d8
and in the meantime white still has to
solve what's going on on the kingside
well LaVon said let me shut down the
King site as best I can
c5 attacking the Queen so where can
white move his Queen if he moves it to
d5 well thank you very much I have this
offside Knight over here Queen d5
I'll just retreat with a gain of time
against the Queen so Queen d5 is just a
terrible move again this pawn on e4 is
hanging so we need a good square for the
Queen which one
Queen a4 check but the bishop would
develop with a gain of a tempo if you
put your queen on e3 which is completely
reasonable of course I think blacks plan
will be to develop the Bishop d7 with
the idea of Bishop seasick to Castle and
then to focus on this pawn on e4 also
the Queen on e3 does interfere with the
natural development of this Bishop bless
you so maybe the bishop would like to
come out LaVon played Queen C for Bishop
e6 and here LaVon did make an error he
played Queen b5 check
I don't like White's position I think
he's been thoroughly outplayed and black
is for choice but he had to he had to
step back with his Queen Queen d2 and
black is going to Castle and black is
going to eventually start excuse me
black is eventually going to start to
play moves like Bishop d5 and f5
it's all very nice so Bishop come out
check c6 where you gonna put your queen
dude
Queen a4 so somehow in this little dance
with the Queen
LaVon had convinced himself that oops
that the pawn on a7 was a potential
weakness the Queen defends the pawn on
e4 and that was that this was somehow
the most suitable line of play
suggestions for black b5 very
attractive-looking move it is a second
lets you see a new variation I think the
problem is that here now there is this
direct threat and maybe the Queen is
annoying on a6 now the suggestion yes
f-five bravo Bravo
f5 essentially Vladimir is just trying
to get at the guys King he wants some
variation that might go takes Bishop
Shaq King for example here Queen to e2
eyeballing not only the rook but maybe
an opportunity to line up on this
diagonal and then after a move excuse me
like 92 castles and white is stuck
white is stuck four moves f5 OOP scuse
me f5 and Bishop g5
okay development is good comes a little
late with development is good yeah sack
just sacrifice that exchange Bongo now
comes a key key key moment
what's the follow-up what's the follow I
noticed everybody was brave and
sacrificing the exchange then now you've
got to get make a key follow-up move
Queen takes g5 is a nice move by me b5
may be the same issue as before though
Queen a6 and we got some issues avoided
very definitely in berserk mode let's
sacrifice away but sacrifice away Queen
takes g5 is a very decent looking move
so I have this theory in chess okay and
it basically goes like this sometimes I
play really really really badly like I'm
just I can't even recognize myself I put
my pieces in awkward and poor positions
so having gotten myself into a mess by
putting my pieces on bad squares I try
to justify why they're there right I
look for variations which make the piece
that appears to be stupid to actually be
wonderful in this position the night on
h5 obviously does not want to be there
it wants to be on that three it wants to
be on the e4 and when yes suddenly this
night that is super stupid stuck off on
the side of the board when you follow up
with the move f4 rut row suddenly this
Knight is playing an enormous role
obviously this pawn on g3 is under
attack
this Queen can now happily capture this
pawn and even worse damages to come we
can imagine that g3 is our new target
right we're just focusing our energy
g3 but we can imagine that black would
like to castle and go rook to d3 and g3
is falling Queen comes back to d1 okay
LaVon is you know really scrambling to
now trying to save the game rook to d8
Queen takes g5 is a very good move takes
on g3 is a very good move in this
position that's actually black who's
simply winning the game and it's a
question of style now how do you want to
win I must say I would be very attracted
to taking on g3 as well as Queen takes
g5 but in fact you know when you're
having a party
invite everybody invite everybody make
sure everybody's coming to the party and
that rook on the a8 you know it's not a
member of the party you got to bring it
into the game so rook to d8 gaining a
tempo on the Queen Queen to c1 so what
did Latimer play now Knight takes g3
looks very attractive are we sure it
wins though or after Queen g5 first that
looks really good Queen g5 first
followed by more more guys how about
look d3
ooh how about rook g3 planting that rook
in the center of the board threatening
all kinds of nasties on g3 on g3 on ya
rook to d3 sorry rook to d3 hitting the
g3 font whoo
some very attractive you know when you
have such a wonderful attacking position
you know it's easy to find good moves
takes it's coming right Knight to a3 and
now this DoubleX clan move right no III
rook to d1 and now we have the big
moment so essentially this night on G on
h5 is really participating black pardon
me white could never recapture the pawn
because then the knight would capture on
g3 with a check and that would be
winning the rook has penetrated here I
was expecting a move like rook f3 to be
honest I thought that was a really good
move but Vladimir had seen deeper he'd
seen a nicer continuation he knew
reasons that his bishop on e6 really
wants to get into the game
is there a difference between Bishop to
f5 and Bishop to d5
I like the move Bishop d5 a lot more I'm
I'm I'm really partial to absolute pins
right when I get the opportunity to make
an absolute pin it's almost a 90
percenter that I'm going to choose it
over a move like Bishop f5 I think
they're both really good moves
I just loved this Bishop d5 and you're
lining up with the King on the diagonal
young-ran exactly so what do you think
what do you think what's what's going on
how come white can't just take the
bishop what do you think what do you see
that would be really really bad for
White Queen e4 check now there's only
one square that white can move this King
right and now what's the really bad news
Knight f4 is very strong but you have
something even more forcing so your job
when you're on the 10th on the attack is
to remember you always look at the most
forcing moves first so the most forcing
moves are always checks right cuz you
got to answer a check and the second
most forcing moves are captures so
Knight f4 is a good manoeuvring move I
like that move yes G takes f 2 check and
then what would you do King takes F 2
Queen f3 check ok and then what if I go
back
Queen the g3 check they look at the most
forcing moves first and they're always
checks another check bravo Bravo be very
good very good
no choice okay now this is interesting
because this is a stylistic thing when I
play blitz online so I've got certain
patterns where I I make these major
piece mates so Queen h2 rook g1 but I
would just play rook g2 Queen h1 so
which one
I mean it's checkmate in two but I I'm
used to the rook G to green H and check
me so that's why you can't take the
bishop you answered your own question
what do you need me for
Bishop to d5 okay you can't take the
bishop what are we gonna do we're in
trouble big time okay let's see you
played that three so why didn't so first
of all why didn't he take the take on d3
why didn't he take the rook let me ask
you a question
because you well I'm not sure but I
don't know what I'm up actually are you
sure you want to play Bishop takes e4
Queen takes e4 check now I'm threatening
Queen to go to h1 checkmate you have to
play f3 now what do you did Queen takes
d3 and this is a yeah this is a complete
winning variation for white so that's
why LaVon didn't take the rook that's
why he didn't take the bishop he played
f3 rook to f1 the same thing is
happening the rook to e1 okay sorry just
a second new variation rook to e1 okay
so new variation yep okay Bishop b4 is
really good
g3 takes f2 attacking the rook that's
really good but let's look at the checks
first right so we look at the check
first and then the King comes to okay
check King wit Delilah's oh there's
three checks if you're just gonna throw
them out there Queen f7 check King has
to drop back rook g3 check but although
King here
yeah checkmate
ooh so now we understand why he can't
take the bishop he can't take the rook
can't play rook e1 he came up with f3
trying his best to block this
LightSquared diagonal that his king is
upon okay so you got lots of choices
here lots and lots and lots of choices
what are you gonna do G to check I think
he's supposed to play king g1 I don't
think he should I know I know don't you
hate that when the guy does yeah no this
would be kind of playing easy this would
make yeah yeah exactly this would make
black's life a little easier so what did
black do what did black did take my
bishop take my rook whichever one you
want to do now the problem is if we take
the rook especially the Queen takes here
mate if you play rook III check me I did
that this had been in the earlier
lecture the secret life of a pond
[Laughter]
no no no I I would go to the bathroom
crawl out the bathroom window and like
run home to mom okay
f3 oops sorry
f3 g takes f3 lavon's move what are you
gonna do what are you gonna do all of
these checkmate staring you in the head
took the bishop mmm what did blat Amir
play now
f2 looks like a very strong move F to G
to check
maybe the king can go to g1 I'm not sure
Queen e2 I really really like because
when the excuse me
Queen e2 I really really like because
when the Queen posts up on e - you got a
to check mating threats now I noticed
mr. ken west that you were the one who
came up with Queen e2 and in the bill
right you know st. Louis open you
managed to lose your queen and a couple
of the games so I was waiting for you to
come up with the Queen sack of ice and
you did very well
rook to e1 now g2 check I think LaVon
resigned which is a kind of a pity
because it's clear if we play King here
well that makes white blacks life very
simple f2 check and you could probably
like double checkmate or something I'm
not sure that Bishop
maybe not me I mean I'll be I'm not sure
I think it may be wait actually you're
right but okay but I would I was a
little bit disappointed because LaVon
understands that he's actually the
victim of a brilliancy and I was hoping
that he would play the move king h2 now
what do you guys do
correct
nice you just play g2 so that you could
get rid of the pond with a double check
how cool a little monstrous is that I
mean if you could get away I know I know
you're right
queen g2 check would be checkmate except
it's illegal
yes so well how do you win what's the
winning sequence f2 check hold on no if
I go king h2 well that's easy that's a
that's discovered check and that that's
terrible
how about king h1 just a second whoa
what are we gonna do
f1 promote that is a check made into no
question I thought that this was the
most let us say vicious it's not often
that you get double check mated by two
queens and it's sort of like oh my gosh
you know this is horrible with one being
pinned in an absolute way as well I
think that if LaVon had allowed this
finish he would have been the one
getting me applauds because it's a it's
a very very very nice game so here it is
you know the life of a professional you
know you got to live and die by your
novelties you come to the tournament
games you're super super well prepared
and like llegaste
I never got a chance to play it now
again this is this whole idea of rook g8
+ g5 had been sitting in Vladimir's
pocket his war chest for better part of
two years and he just knows somebody's
gonna discover it before him before he
gets a chance and on the biggest stage
bang oh yes and it will happen of course
again and again that you know that's why
you work so hard so you can get an
opportunity like this the whole problem
is that sometimes you know your
opponents just don't cooperate like they
should you don't like
just know that mean persons thank you
all for coming to tonight
[Applause]
[Music]